[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans face
aux territoires sur tv5monde en direct
est également en direct sur les sites
internet de nos partenaires co
producteur ouest france.fr nicematin.com
et franceantilles.fr avec un léger
différé pour eux dû vous le savez au
décalage horaire bonjour a tous notre
invité ce matin c'est françois hollande
bonjour françois hollande bonjour d'être
avec nous l'actualité est dramatique ce
matin vous le savez françois hollande
avec un bilan de 27 morts naufrage au
large de calais une réunion
interministérielle est prévue ce matin
ce 5 passes et ont été interpellés
d'ailleurs on le sait maintenant et
c'est un canot pneumatique sans doute
éventré qui a causé la mort de ces
migrants doubler votre votre réaction
face à ce drame j'ai à dire ce nouveau
drame dont on a peur qu'il soit oublié
dans quelques jours oui c'est une
tragédie épouvantable qui heurte
bouleverse par l'ampleur des morts et
des personnes qui ont failli mourir et
qui ont été heureusement secourus et qui
vient après d'autres drames dont on
parle peu tous ces migrants qui essayent
sur des embarcations de fortune d'aller
vers le royaume-uni de la france donc
que faire au delà de la compassion de la
solidarité que l'on doit avoir avec ses
victimes ça révèle que le système de
contrôle des frontières entre la france
et le royaume uni depuis le break si tu
ne peux pas être maintenues en l'état et
que j'imagine que ce sera la
responsabilité du gouvernement français
que de demander avec les britanniques
d'avoir un mécanisme de surveillance de
contrôle est aussi d'accueil de ces
migrants qui puisse éviter que l'on
puisse retrouver des drames françois
hollande vous êtes avec nous pour 40
minutes en direct nous allons parler
territoire nous allons parler politique
internationale dans un instant tout de
suite françois xavier le franc le
rédacteur en chef de ouest france nous
rejoint sur ce bateau
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier leuridan chef du
plus grand quotidien français pommier
cantilien de langue française au monde
d'ailleurs merci d'être avec nous ce
matin vous êtes partenaires de cette
émission dans un instant on va parler
avec vous bien sûr de l'inégalité dans
les territoires d'outre-mer nouvelle
calédonie et autres mets tout de suite
point de départ de la crise actuelle aux
antilles c'est l'obligation vaccinale
pour les soignants à fort-de-france le
directeur des rédactions de france
antilles cyril bouty est partenaire de
cette émission une question posée
françois hollande on écoute bonjour
françois hollande vous évoquez avec
françois-xavier lefranc les inégalités
dont souffrent les outre-mer ici aux
antilles en guadeloupe en martinique
nous sommes en pleine crise sociale
le point de départ de cette crise c'est
le refus de l'obligation vaccinale pour
les soignants pour les sapeurs pompiers
c'est une loi de la république qui
s'applique à l'ensemble du territoire le
gouvernement l'a réaffirmé par la voix
du premier ministre par la voix du
ministre de la santé
comment selon vous on peut répondre à
cette revendication
est et comment sortir de cette de cette
ornière dans laquelle sont en train de
s'enfoncer la guadeloupe et la
martinique
oui vous avez raison d'insister il y as
aux antilles en martinique en guadeloupe
une crise sociale qui couvait depuis
déjà plusieurs mois pour ne pas dire
plusieurs années et qui
utilise aussi une difficulté vous l'avez
rappelé l'obligation vaccinale pour
émerger et pour submerger même la
guadeloupe et la martinique donc la
première réponse elle doit être social
alors pour l'obligation vaccinale c'est
une loi de la république et il est
difficile d'imaginer qu'elle puisse être
aménagés pour un territoire en
particulier si on pense et je le pense
que le vaccin est la solution c'est
quand même très préjudiciable de trouver
un territoire où cette règle ne
s'appliquerait pas est-ce qu'il faut
avoir des modalités particulières ça
c'est un dialogue qui doit s'engager je
crois qu'il est d'ailleurs déjà mené
mais
est-ce qu'il faut multiplier les tests
pour que les personnels ne soit pas
empêché travailler alors qu'on a
absolument besoin ça peut être une
solution mais on ne pourra pas répondre
à cette peur sur le vaccin exagéré
utiliser manipuler parfois si on ne
répond pas à la crise sociale je veux
dire un dernier mot c'est que les
violences sont extrêmement
préjudiciable est grave il faut qu'elle
cesse ça c'est un appel je pense à la
responsabilité que tous les élus et tous
les responsables doivent avoir mais
d'abord c'est au gouvernement de mener
ce dialogue françois des préoccupations
sociales
lefranc vous pose sa question christiane
taubira votre ancienne garde des sceaux
n'a pas beaucoup aidé dans cette affaire
lorsqu'elle s'était
vous rappeler qu'à prononcer non pas
contre la vaccination mais en est ambigu
sur le sujet je sais pas ce qu'elle a
voulu signifier exactement mais c'est
vrai qu'ils m'aiment bien vous ne savez
pas ce que là vous leur métier
exactement c'est à elle de répondre
parce que elle n'a pas condamné le
vaccin il a dit combien il y avait un
vécu envie qu'il y avait de
l'appréhension est de ce point lune nous
savons qu'il ya eu des précédents
historiques qui font que une partie de
la population sans doute pas forcément
bien informées quelquefois même
manipulé par des complotistes mais il
est vrai que il y a eu des précédents
donc il est très important de donner des
garanties à la population comme nous le
faisons par tous sur l'enjeu vaccinale
monsieur hollande vous l'avez dit cette
affaire allait aussi révélatrice d'un
sentiment de défiance qui existe dans
les territoires d'outre-mer à l'égard de
l'état la pauvreté y est plus importante
qu'ailleurs c'est une réalité comment
aujourd'hui peut-on renouer le lien de
confiance entre entre l'état entre la
métropole et les territoires d'outre-mer
on découvre une nouvelle fois qu'il y à
des inégalités des disparités des
retards qui sont inacceptables en
outre-mer par rapport à ce qui se passe
qui n'est pas forcément simple en
métropole et je pense que ce sont des
territoires qui ont été peu à peu oublié
j'avais fait deux mois de l'outre-mer
une priorité c'est pas simplement des
mesures fiscales ce sont des mesures de
parité sociale ce sont des mesures
d'emploi quel est le problème que l'on a
aux antilles alors que en métropole le
chômage connaît et heureusement une
baisse c'est qu'on a un sous-emploi très
important du taux d'emploi l'emploi les
jeunes réformation un taux d'emploi
publics très élevés parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'emplois privés donc la première
condition pour que les antilles les
territoires d'outre-mer d'une manière
générale retrouvent confiance c'est
qu'il y ait une politique d'antaloor et
qui ne peut pas être réduite au seul
tourisme et en outre mer c'est aussi la
nouvelle calédonie où l'on va voter le
12 décembre prochain le référendum donc
c'est le la suite d'un très long
processus qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce référendum les calédoniens vont dire
s'ils souhaitent rester
intégrer la france
d'abord il y a un doute sur la
participation à ce référendum les
indépendantistes la parti
indépendantiste donc il faudrait pas que
ce soit un troisième référendum si je
puis dire pour rien qu'ils soient
contestés dès qu'il a eu lieu donc ça
mériterait je pense une concertation
générale avant que ce référendum puisse
se tenir de toute façon s'il se tenait
ce qui est aujourd'hui prévu il pourrait
pas être considérés comme un règlement
définitif de l'avenir de la calédonie
alors la question d'inégalité dans les
territoires outre-mer mais aussi en
métropole ça résonne souvent avec une
demande très forte d'une d'un nouvel
élan démocratique comment est-ce qu'on
peut relancer la démocratie à l'échelle
locale et nous avons une question oui
comment développer donc ce concept de
démocratie réelle françois hollande
alors françois franck dubray pardon et
philippe et caldwell france ont
rencontré à saint denis de la réunion
nelson navin écoutons leur semble
bonjour monsieur aux langues j'aimerais
vous demander
enfin vous avez souvent président se
développer le concept d'égalité réelle
j'aimerais savoir en fait quand est-ce
qu'on pourrait développer un concept de
démocratie réelle puisque je pense qu'on
a le clan tous besoin en fait d'avoir
une vision claire de ce qu'est la
démocratie est temps que ce qu'elle me
semble de plus en plus menacé merci
vous rappeler ce que avait été une loi
que madame ait cabaret de la réunion
avait porté en tant que membre du
gouvernement sur l'égalité réelle faire
que ce ne soient pas simplement des
prestations qu'ils soient proposées mais
qu'on aille au plus profond de la cause
de ces inégalités sur la démocratie
réelle on pourrait dire mais tout va
bien il ya des élections régulièrement à
la réunion dans les territoires
d'outre-mer il ya des élections locales
et d'élections législatives non on voit
bien que le processus électoral ne
suffit plus et qu'il y a besoin de
participation nous l'avons vieux
également métropole avec la caisse
régionale les jaunes nous avons vu aussi
qu'il y avait une abstention très forte
au moment des élections régionales et
départementales alors que c'était des
scrutins qui jusqu'à présent mobilisent
et les concitoyens donc il y a des
formes de participation lesquels de
consultations régulières je pense que
sur certains projets il y en a à la
réunion il ya une nécessité d'avoir
davantage de l'or en plomb les
référendums votation sur un certain
nombre de sujets très précis
deuxièmement de concertation plus grande
qu'il n'y en a aujourd'hui avec les
reprend dans ce qu'on appelle les corps
intermédiaires
parce qu'on a besoin des corps
intermédiaires une des erreurs qui a été
commise a été de penser qu'on pouvait
aller directement vers le citoyen enfin
j'ajoute il y a le souci d'une nouvelle
étape de décentralisation
ces territoires besoin quand ils en ont
besoin de nouvelles compétences dans les
territoires ils ont besoin que l'état
leur fasse confiance et souvent ils ont
un sentiment de défiance est-ce qu'il
faut une nouvelle réforme qu'elle
pourrait être vous avez réformer les
régions françaises est ce qu'il faut
aller beaucoup plus loin quelle pourrait
être la grande réforme des territoires
la nouvelle organisation des territoires
qui permettrait justement ce nouvel élan
démocratique qui est attendu pour ce que
j'ai fait sous durant mon quinquennat ça
a été de refaire la carte des régions ce
que j'ai fait aussi c'est de trouver
assez très critiqué françois hollande au
journal de critiquer mais va plus
personne ne remet en cause cette carte
des régions les régions certaines
régions sont mécontentes de ce découpage
encore qu'une région où on a trouvé une
adaptation c'est l'alsace enfin c'était
la grande thèse et on a créé une
collectivité
alsace mais pour le reste je n'ai pas vu
de famille politique remettait en cause
ce cadre là donc on a redessiné les
régions on a maintenu les départements
je pense que c'était nécessaire pour la
proximité on a conforté le bloc communal
avec l'intercommunalité mais mais je
suis tout à fait conscient qu'on est pas
allé jusqu'au bout il faut maintenant
vous dans ce cadre-là décentralisée il a
fait transférer de nouvelles compétences
vous lesquels lesquels parce que
finalement les régions notamment sur
l'emploi demande à être beaucoup plus
intervenants j'y suis moi tout à fait
prêts sur mais les citoyens ne s'y
retrouvent plus vous la ville n'ont pas
voté les jeunes neuf jeunes sur dix
n'ont pas voté mais ses passes 4 ans en
fait les gens ne comprennent pas comment
tout ça fonctionne ne comprennent pas
les différents niveaux de décision à ce
qu'il faut pas clarifier cela alors
françois hollande justement quelles
réformes pour les territoires le 11
novembre dernier c'est manuel valls
votre ancien premier ministre était
notre invité sur ce plateau il disait
ceci à propos du millefeuille
territorial regarder je considère que
l'un de nos échecs en 2012 c'est alors
que la gauche gouvernait le pays avait
tous les pouvoirs présidence de
l'assemblée nationale sénat et bien sûr
la plupart des collectivités
territoriales n'y a pas une vision
d'ensemble nous permettent de nous
attaquer au sujet de je pense que sur
les compétences de la santé nous voulons
de le dire sur l'emploi pôle emploi la
formation même si beaucoup a été fait le
développement économique il faut
clarifier les compétences et qui fait
quoi au fond les régions voient bien on
la stratégie l'économie la santé les
départements les questions sociales
l'intercommunalité les communes la
réalité locale je ne suis pas sûr que
nous soyons obligés de passer par la
suppression d'une collectivité mais une
clarification et des compétences
nouvelles assumé par les collectivités
oui incontestablement oui là je vais
j'allais dire de faisant doublon manuel
valls dit ce que je viens ce n'est pas
une vision d'ensemble mais nous l'avons
nous la rive sud il a d'ailleurs il l'a
rappelé qu'en dix ans l'économie pour
les régions le social pour les
départements et le bloc communal pour
assurer la vie au quotidien mais je
reviens qu'est-ce qu'il faut clarifier
il faut dire qu est ce que fait la
région elle fait de l'économie de
l'emploi du développement et de l'action
écologique donc il faut que tout ce qui
est sur ces domaines là pour l'instant
de la compétence de l'état viennent vers
les régions avec les ressources
correspondantes c'est à dire avec un
transfert de fiscalité pour le social le
département moi je suis favorable à ce
que le département soit la collectivité
sociale et du tchad et régions sont très
faibles sur une part mais il ya des
régions européennes ca c je suis
d'accord mais d'abord vous dire qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire à l'échelle du
territoire une fois qu'on a dit ça quel
transfert de deux impôts le gouvernement
actuel président macro ont supprimé
l'imposition locale taxe d'habitation et
il n'y avait déjà plus de l'impôt sur
les entreprises avec la suppression
c'était sous nicolas sarkozy de la taxe
professionnelle donc ça ne peut plus
faire en donnant à créer un nouvel impôt
on va créer un nouvel impôt donc la
seule chose que nous pouvons faire c'est
ce que j'avais fait pour les régions
s'est transféré des départs de tva vers
les régions et des parts de csg vers les
départements françois-xavier lefranc
chaunu qui est dessinateur de ouest
france une question à poser à françois
hollande c'est la tradition de cette
émission l'écoutent monsieur le
président
monsieur le président dans une époque où
les médecins ont remplacé les hommes
politiques le parti socialiste est bien
malade et la candidature dany dago prend
l'eau alors la question que je vous pose
françois hollande l'elysée est ce que ça
vous gratouille
ou est-ce que ça vous chatouille
bassam a déjà occupé pendant cinq ans
donc je ne suis pas en manque je ne suis
pas là en me disant mais la présidence
de la rue il ne peut pas vivre sans moi
il faut que je me dévoue que vous dites
sur ce plateau ce matin vous ne serez
pas candidat anne hidalgo et la
candidate elle a été choisi par le parti
socialiste je suis là soutient je suis
socialiste depuis toujours je le
resterai je crois jusqu'à la fin de mes
jours après c'est à elle de donner des
éléments de ce programme parce que ce
que je vais dire d'une manière générale
c'est que nous ne sommes pas rentrés
dans la campagne présidentielle d'abord
parce à partir du camp votre avis les
français au mois de janvier nous ne
connaissons pas encore les candidats le
candidat notamment dlr emmanuel macron
même si ça paraît probable il va être
candidat à sa réélection donc il est
important qu'on ait la liste des
candidats ensuite la politique ce sont
des programmes aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de programme il ya des propositions qui
aimait émergent ici ou là des
surenchères notamment en matière de
sécurité et d'immigration mais je pense
que pour anne hidalgo le plus essentiel
si j'avais un conseil à lui donner c'est
de faire un programme à une ouest france
france info il a une de ouest france
c'est ce drame a minable et révoltant
des migrants entre ce qui s'est passé
entre la france et le royaume uni est
une réflexion aussi sur le nouveau
pouvoir en allemagne avec cette
coalition à trois assez inédite mais
c'est important que le lien
franco-allemand dans cette période et
notamment face à ces tragédies soit à
l'action et donc ce nouveau pouvoir est
en train de se mettre en place ce rendez
vous l'avez majeur merci françois xavier
le franc et là je veux dire juste avant
là dessus
j'ai grande confiance dans
l'équipe qui vient d'être constitué par
olaf scholz que je connais qui était le
numéro deux du gouvernement merkel dans
le cadre d'une coalition
le plan parce que nous parlons de
programmes et peut-être prenons exemple
sur ce que font nos amis allemands le
contrat de coalition il fait 150 pages
il a été élaboré pendant trois mois et
donc les annonces savent ce que va être
le travail de cette équipe mais par
rapport à l'enjeu européen
il y aura sans doute un rappel à l'ordre
sur le plan budgétaire passe codaf soft
n'est pas un laxiste donc ça veut dire
que pour le président français de 2022
il aura travaillé avec olaf york pour
mettre un peu de un coup d'arrêt à la
montée des dépenses publiques et de la
dette publique et deuxièmement contexte
d'inflation et est deuxième on s'est un
gouvernement où l'écologie a été
considérée enfin la lutte contre le
réchauffement comme prioritaires et je
pense que là aussi ça peut être pour le
couple franco allemand un très bon axe
voilà vous avez conseillé à anne hidalgo
j'ai entendu tout à l'heure d'avoir un
programme mais comme à tout candidat je
pense que c'est très important que les
français sachent si ce que l'on rend
leur propose un peu comme nos amis
allemands viennent de le faire pour les
cinq prochaines années françois-xavier
lefranc merci à vous de nous car audio
et dans un instant sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot êtes le directeur
des rédactions de nice-matin partenaires
et coproducteurs de cette émission merci
d'être avec nous tout de suite on va
partir du côté de la corrèze un
département vous connaissez bien
françois hollande que de couvrot pas
nice matin il faut quand même bien le
dire et c'est pour ça que nous avons
comme partenaire pour cette émission la
montagne centre france florence fait
dota l'éditorialiste donc chez centre
france la montagne à une question à vous
poser françois hollande on écoute ce
sont des images de gregory gomez de la
montagne à 4 montferrand françois
hollande bonjour vous étiez récemment
chez nous donc chez vous en corrèze à
l'occasion de la foire du livre de brive
vous avez dédicacer votre dernier essai
dès la première page vous abordé
l'accord est ce département là où tout a
commencé pour vous politiquement mais
dans la foulée vous expliquer qu'au
moment de quitter la présidence
française vous avez préféré garder la
corrèze non pas comme terre d'élection
mais comme havre de quiétude est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
cheminement
je dois tout à la corrèze puisque j'ai j
ai été élu à partir de 1983 j'ai été
parlementaire à partir de 1988 donc elle
m'a fait confiance et elle m'a permis de
poursuivre mon mandat national de
députés puis ensuite de premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
et si je suis devenu président de la
réplique c'est parce que j'avais eu au
préalable la confiance des corréziens
pour diriger leur département à partir
de là quand j'ai quitté l'elysée
j'aurais pu briller aussi valéry giscard
d'estaing est revenu en haut vers le puy
de dôme il n'avait repris un même mandat
de consensus
donc j'aurais pu refaire ce parcours là
mais il ya des femmes et des hommes qui
occupe ses fonctions et je les respecte
et moi même je ne voulais pas répéter ma
vie mais je ne pouvais pas non plus b
loyer de la corrèze donc c'est pour ça
que aujourd'hui j'y reviens non plus
comme élu mais comme citoyen heureux
d'avoir défendu le département est
toujours attentif à ce qui peut s'y
produiront immigration et insécurité
denis carot dans l'actualité oui
françois hollande on a évoqué en début
d'émission le drame des migrants à
calais la question de l'immigration le
voit occupe énormément de place en ce
moment notamment à travers les propos
d'eric zemmour ou les débats des
républicains mais la gauche est toujours
inaudible sur le sujet comment et c'est
d'ailleurs un chapitre de votre dernier
livre regardez l'immigration en face
regardez l'immigration en face nous
l'avons fait que nous étions aux
responsabilités pendant cinq ans et
d'assurer que les lois soient respectées
certes pour l'entrée sur le territoire
il faut avoir des conditions
soit parce que c'est le droit d'asile
soit parce que c'est le regroupement
familial soit parce que c'est un pour
mener des études ou l'immigration
économique les gens duels sont elles ne
sont pas totalement respecté la loi
elles sont pas respectées pour l'entrée
je pense que il y a encore des
irréguliers et pour le droit d'asile il
est respecté mais les demandeurs d'asile
qui ont été déboutés ne sont pas
raccompagné autant qu'il serait
nécessaire le grand enjeu donc c'est
d'être clair sur les règles d'entrée
mais c'est d'avoir aussi c'est la
condition dans une république
l'application de la règle pour la sortie
c'est ce pas quoi moi j'avais travaillé
qu'il faut continuer à travailler à deux
façons de procéder le premier c'est
d'avoir un accord avec les pays
d'origine pour qu'on puisse les
raccompagner et deuxièmement c'est
d'avoir des procédures juridiques qui
aille beaucoup plus vite quand vous
mettez deux ans trois ans quatre ans
pour raccompagner
et pour décider du raccompagner une
personne qui rentrait illégalement sur
le territoire et bien c'est trop tard
cette personne-là a pu faire des enfants
travail et donc c'est très difficile
donc les deux conditions c'est accélérer
les procédures c'est trop lourd et la
deuxième condition c'est de faire
pression sur les gouvernements
et sur les pays d'origine comment le
faire le gouvernement actuel français a
mis les visages pense pas que ce soit la
formule la plus efficace je pense qu'il
faut avoir un contrat avec chaque pays
en disant nous sommes prêts à payer
indemnisés pour le retour c'est logique
mais vous vous devez accéder sans aide
nous ne pourrons pas le faire je peux le
comprendre mais avec une êtes vous serez
obligés de le faire dans cette
problématique et c'est françois hollande
l'ancien président de la république est
notre invité ce matin en direct sur
tv5monde mirail damiano qui est avocate
au barreau de nice elle pointe elle les
atteintes des droits des mineurs
réfugiés on va l'écouter ce sont des
images de franck fernandez de nice matin
l'assemblée nationale a mis en place une
commission d' enquête sur l'immigration
qui a rendu un rapport le 10 novembre
2021 le constat de ce rapport est assez
alarmant puisque il indique que la
france est dans un état de maltraitance
d'état et un ostracisme envers les
personnes en exil s'agissant des mineurs
il pointe un certain nombre d' atteinte
à leurs droits aux frontières puis lors
de l'évaluation de leur minorité par la
contestation suspicieuse de leurs actes
de naissance et le recours à des tests
osseux peu fiables que pensez vous qu'il
faille soit très fort mais soit
améliorée pour que la france respecte
ses engagements internationaux et les
droits des mineurs à être protégé
la france a des engagements elle doit
les respecter mais elle doit aussi
veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
comportement frauduleux et donc c'est
toute la question des mineurs il y a on
sait très bien des passeurs qui font
venir des personnes qui ne sont pas
nécessairement mineurs et qui ensuite se
déclarant comme tels sont accueillis
dans un certain nombre de départements
la plupart maintenant et obtiennent a
droit au maintien du territoire sur le
territoire donc je pense qu'il faut
éviter des mécanismes effectivement
dégradant de tests osseux etc mais faut
avoir la certitude un moment ou un autre
de l'âge de la personne qui vient sur
notre territoire moi je crois qu'il est
possible de conjuguer fermeté et
humanité sans humanité la fermeté trouve
rapidement et vous avez exprimé avec les
mots qui sont les vôtres une forme de
2,2 de condamnation de ce que propose la
france avec ses valeurs mais s'il n'y a
pas la fermeté de l'humanité devient
impossible regardez ce qui se passe en
ce moment
avec ce drame sur sur calais donc pour
la traversée vers vers le royaume uni
c'est un drame absolu on peut pas
conduire ces personnes jusqu'à calais
pour les laisser sans solution donc
c'est avant que nous devons traiter le
problème ça ne peut être d'ailleurs
qu'une réponse européenne c'est en ce
sens que les les souverainistes et
nationalistes trouvent les limites parce
que rétablir les frontières nationales
d'abord serait contraire à tous le droit
européen et deuxièmement s'il n'ya pas
frontex est à dire une surveillance aux
frontières eh bien on aura toujours ces
drames qui se produiront ou cette
inhumanité qui sera relevé les
évolutions dans la société denis karoui
sur les questions de société à votre
quinquennat a été marqué par une réforme
très importante le mariage pour tous est
ce que d'autres évolutions sont
aujourd'hui nécessaires vous parlez
notamment dans votre livre de la
multiplication inattendue est
vertigineuse des cas particuliers
d'orientation sexuelle est ce qu'il faut
en tenir compte
il faut autant te dire conduit mais il
faut
que chacun devienne pas demander une
solution individus individuel nous
sommes dans une république où nous avons
des droits c'est ce qu'on apercevait
aujourd'hui vous truies la tendance sur
cette île à cette tendance existe et
dire à considérer que toute fraction du
pays toute minorité même très faible à
des droits particuliers oui il fait cela
agace la majorité il faut éviter les
discriminations mais ça ça peut parfois
rendre difficile à comprendre
la majorité des concitoyens ce que
vivent un certain nombre de minorités
donc ça suppose que s'il des droits
doivent être un moment avancé je pense
notamment pour parler d'un exemple
concret pour les transsexuels note avoir
une comme nous l'avons fait d'ailleurs
pour le mariage
de personnes de même c'est d'avoir un
débat qui permette de comprendre qu'on
reste dans les lois de la république
sinon bien on voit ce qui se passe il ya
des extrémistes des polémistes qui vont
dire mais alors où est passée la france
où est notre identité alors qu' il y à
des vagues de france ça nourrit leur
discours bien sûr que ça nourrit le 10
mai les deux d'ailleurs quelquefois seul
se font face et et s'entretiennent moi
je suis pour que donc on puisse avoir
une reconnaissance d'un certain nombre
de situations mais que l'on reste dans
le cadre républicain universaliste que
nous connaissons la semaine dernière
rama yade a estimé que le racisme était
partout en france elle explique vivre
une micro agression quand elle passe
devant la statue de colbert est ce que
la montée de ctp idéologie ou au cou
vous gêne ou est-ce qu'on doit au
contraire regardez l'histoire avec un
prisme actuelle et en complément est ce
que président de la république vous
l'avez vu monter ça
oui je l'avais vu monter dans toutes les
reconnaissances mémorielle puisque
beaucoup de personnes jugent que nous
n'avons pas rendu justice mme un certain
nombre de drames ou un certain nombre de
souffrances qui ont été endurées par
leurs parents par leurs grands parents
donc la discrimination n'est pas
simplement dans dans la vie de tous les
jours elle est aussi dans les stigmates
que un certain nombre de situations de
soumission d'oppression d'exploitation
ont pu laisser produire je peux
comprendre que rama yade soit
aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle vit un opus
aux états unis sensible à ces questions
là donc il faut re bien sûr comprendre
pourquoi il y a encore ses cicatrices
mais je le dis d'ailleurs dans mon livre
on ne peut pas non plus faire de chaque
cas une reconnaissance ou une
revendications mémorielles nous avons
tous dans notre histoire familiale au dd
des sujets qui nous ont heurté est-ce
qu'il faut que ce soit
la république qui à chaque fois face à
un travail c'est le rôle gr d'une
société avec ses historiens ces
intellectuels tout ne doit pas passer
par des reconnaissances qui serait
infinie mais nous devons avoir cette
sensibilité que les discriminations
existent et qu'elles ne sont pas
simplement ce qui est déjà beaucoup dans
l'accès à l'emploi ou dans l'axé la
culture françois hollande l'ancien
président de la république est notre
invité en direct sur ce plateau danse et
v5 monde paco à onze ans françois
hollande il est élève de 3e très en
avance 1 pour son âge l'élève de
troisième il a une question à vous poser
et nice matin à la rencontre et franck
fernandez bonjour monsieur le président
la république si longtemps et je suis en
classe de troisième j'aurai une question
à vous poser comment fait-on pour
devenir président de la république
française
il est bientôt prêt lui il s'était mis
dans la tenue il a déjà une certaine
perception de les plus jeunes qui manuel
macron quand il s'est présenté oui enfin
il n'a pas encore l'âge pour accéder à
la fonction mais c'est bien qu'il y ait
des jeunes qui se disent comment je peux
servir mon pays bon y'a pas que par la
présidence de la république mais comment
je peux aussi me projeter pour être un
moment celui celle qui va diriger la
france mais bon je crois que c'est très
important s'est pas suffisamment fait
qu'il y ait de l'enseignement
syvie instruction civique android os x
voterai pas que ça existe bien sûr
puisque nous l'avons créé dans cetet
najat vallaud belkacem qui en avait pris
la responsabilité mais il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin moi j'ai fait des
livres pour les jeunes pour que ils
sachent ce que sont les électeurs et je
les ai faits d'ailleurs ces livres pour
expliquer ce qu'était la sueur pour eux
et pour leurs parents parce que ce que
je relève c'est que souvent maintenant
les parents sont bien moins informés
qu'ils pouvaient être pour leurs propres
parents aux grands parents on voit votre
livre derrière derrière vous une de
nice-matin dany caron de nice matin les
violences faites aux femmes avec la
journée mondiale aujourd'hui et des
signalements en hausse dans les
alpes-maritimes sans discontinuer depuis
sept ans et des solutions qui sont de
plus en plus mises en oeuvre pour lutter
contre contre ce fléau un dernier mot
vous avez un magazine consacré aux tout
jeunes d'ailleurs où on attaque ide qui
ce matin et paco qui vous a interrogé et
1d et des fidèles de kid matin merci
denis carreaux très vite donné ce matin
c'est très importante la parole ce soit
libéré et donc on a de plus en plus de
signalements ce qu'il faut c'est que là
la justice c'est fait aussi pour les
commissariats enregistre maintenant
c'est plein boom puisse agir pour que
ces agressions ne se reproduise pas et
qui est même d'aider des hôtels ou des
appartements qu'ils soient mises à
disposition des femmes voilées compris
c'est françois hollande notre invité ce
matin dans un instant les questions
internationales avec des maîtres cordes
base de tv5monde journalistes à ma
nation
voilà je disais journaliste à la
rédaction de tv5monde
on démarre avec eux la biélorussie
absolument la commission européenne va
dresser une liste une liste noire des
entreprises qui ont participé à
l'acheminement des migrants à la
frontière polonaise
bruxelles vise particulièrement la
compagnie aérienne bellavia
pour lui interdire de louer des avions
européens elirale en est en première
ligne puisque l'irlande lui nous 17
avions sur une flotte d'une trentaine
d'appareils est ce que ce ne sont pas
des demi mesures
pas de n'oublions pas que l'europe
prenne des sanctions et puissent se
punir des entreprises qui se sont
comporté de manière honteuse parce
qu'elles ont été complices de la
biélorussie et soyez soit dit en passant
de la russie qui a qui ont acheminé
délibérément des migrants qui sont allés
les chercher pour les mettre dans des
situations inhumaines à la frontière
polonaise tant que ces entreprises ne
devrait même plus pouvoir travailler
dans dans le ciel européen me serrer 5e
train de sanctions contre les violeurs
ou ici à leur pivot il va falloir
combien de sanctions pour être crédible
l'europe dans ce dans cette situation là
apparaît un peu démuni quand même nom le
plus de sanctions possibles et ne pas
nier non plus le rôle de la russie est
donc continuer à sanctionner de la
russie quels autres moyens le recours à
la force nous ne sommes pas là non
peut-être complètement arrêté les
échanges commerciaux c'est une culture
drc c'est pour partie vrai avec la
biélorussie ça doit l'être sur la
question du gaz russe à un moment est ce
qu'on est capable c'était plus facile
pour la france de de l'exprimer puisque
nous ne dépendons pas majoritairement de
gaz russe mais c'est vrai qu'à un moment
c'est larmes économique principal que
nous pouvons utiliser et là lorsque là
ça fait partie des des différends entre
la france et l'allemagne lorsqu'il ya eu
le projet de de nord stream c'est à dire
du de l'approvisionnement en gaz d'une
partie de l'europe il y avait
effectivement pour vladimir poutine un
moyen d'entrer est un moyen de pression
le moyen d'entrer et de pression c'est
aussi l'ambivalence des européens et
aussi peut-être de la france vis-à-vis
de moscou
est ce que vous y que j'avais été
ambiguë à l'égard de vladimir poutine le
juge il faut dialoguer mais il faut
avoir une position de force et c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup d'hésitations
il ya eu beaucoup de de changement de
pied à l'égard aux élans voyez vous au
dialogue ou à la coopération avec moscou
oui mais sur un rapport de force j'ai
bien
connu vadimir poutine j'ai eu une
multiple réunion de négociation avec lui
c'est pas par simplement notre
intelligence notre séduction notre
charme que l'on peut amener vous la
meilleure poutine vers une position plus
raisonnable c'est avec un rapport de
force il peut être économie qui peut
même être militaire oui quand les
cancans by john a
était plus explicite sur ce que pourrait
faire éventuellement les états unis s'il
y avait une entrée de troupes russes en
ukraine et bien les troupes russes
voulant retirer de la foule des revues
vladimir poutine depuis que vous des
deux présidents n'ont jamais et
justement sur l'ukraine on pense que
c'est le futur conflit dans cette région
du monde les etats unis ont envoyé deux
deux patrouilleurs pour soutenir les
forces navales ukrainienne est ce que
vous craignez un nouveau conflit armé
entre la russie et l'ukraine oui il ya
cessez le feu mais il ya aussi des morts
régulièrement qui sont hélas constatée
du côté ukrainien les soldats donc bien
sûr que vladimir poutine va essayer de
poursuivre son opération c'est-à-dire de
d'avoir un conflit gelé de plus de plus
en plus préoccupant pour pour l'europe
donc la seule manière de faire c'est
quand ils amassent des troupes comme
c'est le cas en ce moment au la
frontière entre la russie et l'ukraine
ces deux d'élever la voix vous avez
rappelé ce qu'avait fait le président
byden en envoyant des patrouilleurs et
bien l'europe aussi donc j'en arrive à
la même position si l'europe veut se
faire respecter il faut qu'il y ait une
europe de la défense si vous n'avez pas
de moyens de coercition si vous n'êtes
pas capables à un moment d'utiliser ou
de laisser penser que vous pouvez
utiliser la force vous êtes une
puissance secondaire l'europe est une
puissance secondaire je ne peux dire que
la france est une puissance secondaire
mais l'europe en tant que tel est une
puissance secondaire dès lors qu'elle
n'a pas une europe de la défense c'est
ce qu' il faudrait par exemple enlever
des troupes au sahel pour les
repositionner dans d'autres en europe
précisément au parti dans les nous avons
tant la partie à la question est ce
qu'on a les moyens d'être partout
françois et nous la france ne pourront
pas être partout si nous avons alors
justement si vous avez voulu faire
l'europe c'est pour être avec d'autres
c'est que pour d'autres s'engagent aussi
passablement d'ailleurs les pays membres
de l'union européenne mais aussi le
royaume uni à une coopération de défense
avec le royaume uni et puis nous avons à
traiter un choc d'ordre dans l'alliance
atlantique dont nous pouvons agir avec
les américains mais la france elle
assume sa défense il faut que les
européens puissent aussi et je pense
qu'ils ne le feront pas à 27 parce que
c'est impossible qu'on va tous les 27
donc faut le faire à quelques pays pour
qu'on ait véritablement des actions
possibles à l'extérieur et pour la
protection de nos frontières alors il y
a interpol qui a qui s'est réuni à
istanbul en assemblée générale et qui
vient d'élire un général émirati accusé
de torture est ce que ça vous choque que
des ces pays autoritaires arrive à
rentrer jusque dans des institutions
occidentales l'afa le monde et est
organisé de cette façon c'est à dire il
n'y a pas que des démocraties dans le
monde les des organisations
internationales hélas sont mutualisés
pour leur présidence ou pour leur
responsabilité
avant c'était un chinois qui d'ailleurs
a eu quelques maille à partir tiens
disparu de la circulation donc il y à un
partage c'est assez regrettable que
quelquefois ça puisse être avec des
personnes qui ne correspondent pas à nos
valeurs mais c'est ainsi ou alors il
servit engagement c'est le désengagement
vient aussi et financier puisque les
émirats arabes unis sont les 2e
contributeur mais vous avez tout à fait
raison
si les démocraties veulent être plus
influentes il faut qu'elle y met de
l'argent qu'est-ce qu'on fait les
chinois depuis plusieurs années c'est
d'être les premiers financeurs et de la
fao et de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé est maintenant de d'interpol pour
meuse et dans les désignations et bien
les démocraties elles doivent se
défendre économiquement ils doivent se
défendre militairement et doivent se
défendre financièrement merci dé m
korkmaz françois hollande 44% des
français estiment qu emmanuel macron est
un bon président c'est un sondage aux
hawks à novembre 2000 21 après quatre
années donc au pouvoir ils retrouvent
des niveaux de popularité qui étaient
les siens au départ vous n'êtes pas en
décalage par rapport aux français
pourquoi je serai en décalage parce qu
on vous entend critiquer france françois
emmanuel macron sur toutes les ondes à
l'occasion de cette promotion de
de ce livre on vous a beaucoup entendu
en critiques du président de république
mais je pense que il ya des critiques
qui peuvent lui être adressées qu'elles
sont partagées par les france que
voulait redresser dans le privé quand
vous voyez je ne pense pas donc je n'ai
pas pu lui dire directement mais je
trouve que ces changements de pied
multiples cette espèce de deux distances
par rapport au pourquoi les français ne
jugent pas parce que les conséquences du
moment oui moi je les comprends ils ont
besoin de cohésion ils ont besoin
d'unité on devine une crise sanitaire
qui non non ne se termine pas où on a
besoin qu'il y ait une autorité chaque
fois qu'il ya une crise je n'ai vécurent
il incarne bien semer oui il la regarde
bien il incarne il la carte d'abord
institutionnellement il faut qu'ils
aient eu une présidence qui puisse
prendre des décisions personnelles mais
directionnelle mans il s'exprime devant
les français et même s'il ya toujours
des critiques on peut faire sur les
masques sur les vaccins etc mais il faut
bien qu'il y ait dans cette période où
nous sommes un peu désemparé compte tenu
de la récurrence du virus faut bien
qu'il y ait un président de la
république qui assume la tâche et je
pense que c'est nécessaire que les
français fassent blanc y compris dans le
par les sondages lorsqu'il ya une crise
il faut être derrière les autorités qui
agissent au nom de l'intérêt général
vous n'avez pas une nostalgie du pouvoir
vous avez vu que les observateurs dit
souvent main françois hollande il
n'arrive pas à décrocher entre
guillemets de cette période là et c'est
pour ça qu'ils critiquent aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron qui a été son successeur
mais si j'étais un accro du pouvoir que
vous vous dites je me serais représenter
à l'élection présidentielle si j'étais
un accro du poids je serais aujourd'hui
candidat si j'étais un accro du pouvoir
la question m'a été posée j'aurais
repris mais mes fonctions antérieures de
mer deux présidents de départements aux
deux défenseurs de jeu j'exprime mes
idées je déforme berne émission
questions et je ne suis pas accroché où
je me suis toujours posé la question
personnellement pourquoi vous n'en avez
pas voulu plus au fond à manuel valls
qui était votre premier ministre karim
annuel macron puisque manuel valls a été
très prégnant impactant dans le le vote
décision de ne pas vous représenter au
fond à l'époque pourquoi non et vous
relations avec lui qui sont distantes
aujourd'hui deux dates de cette taille
là non mais j'ai répondu merci
manuel valls n'a pas été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avant que j'ai
pris bien sûr une décision mais oui
manuel valls a été un premier ministre
loyal pendant toute la période où il a
été auprès de moi ensuite il a pris des
positions qu'ils ont fait contre nous
avons pu nous éloigner je n'étais pas
d'accord sur un certain nombre de
voiliers aujourd'hui d'éclat mais je le
vois plus souvent que manuel macron si
c'est ça la question merci beaucoup
françois hollande alors été neutralité
ils acceptent ce matin d'en face aux
territoires une émission de tv5 monde de
ouest france de nice matin avec la
participation de france antilles et la
rédaction de tv5monde des maîtres merci
à vous on se retrouve jeudi prochain en
direct sophie cluzel qui est la socata
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
sera notre invité dans cette émission au
revoir à tous les programmes continus
sur tv5 monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]